thank you for patience we have listened
intently to both the presentations and
the representations that have been made
to us
um this evening and we've tried to
compare those with the
regulation and the actual operation of
the licensing Act
and our decision at this point is that
the license should be granted
with the following conditions
the first a major condition the
Licensing hours will extend to 23.59
on Sunday through Thursday
but be extendable to oh 100 hours on
Friday and Saturday
and similar time oh 100 hours on New
Year's Eve
whenever that might fall in the in the
week
we would also
apply the condition that there will be
no outside music
and to put that to one side we recognize
from your representation your
presentation that you have no plans for
that but we're going to make that a
definite condition
and that outside areas outside drinking
areas
should close at 2100 hours on all days
so although you're remaining open until
23 59 to contain that within the
building
and and with the
with those conditions applied to the
license
thank you for your time thank you for
your time and I hope that over the
coming years you will find that you can
merge into each other's lives
the positive way as possible thank you
for your time and thank you for your
time thank you